Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Salam aleykoum.
Dans ma tradition, on se salue
en se souhaitant la paix.
« Salam aleykoum » veut dire en arabe
« que la paix soit sur vous ».
Dans ma tradition, on dit aussi
que la vie, c’est comme un voyage,
qu’il a un début et une fin,
qu’il est fait de facilités,
de difficultés et d’épreuves.
Aujourd’hui, j’ai envie de vous raconter
ce qui a été l’expérience
la plus éprouvante de ma vie.
Le voyage de mes parents, Habiba et Ahmed,
s’est brutalement interrompu
un 7 mai 2002,
ici à Bruxelles, à Schaerbeek.
Notre voisin d’immeuble,
notoirement raciste,
est entré dans notre appartement
et s’est mis à tirer.
Il y a mis le feu.
Il a tué mes parents,
avant de se donner la mort.
Il a blessé mes deux petits frères,
Yassine et Walid,
qui n’avaient que six et onze ans.
J'aurais pu ne pas être ici, devant vous.
À ce moment-là, je n’avais que 18 ans.
Je me suis demandé ce qu’on allait
devenir sans mes parents,
et surtout, comment on en était arrivé là.
Et là, j’ai commencé un long cheminement,
une longue quête,
pour comprendre,
et j’ai prié de toutes mes forces
pour rester debout.
J’aurais pu mourir cette nuit-là.
J’aurais pu me dire que,
puisque l’irréparable avait été commis,
il n’y avait plus rien à faire,
que c’était la fin de tout.
Et puis avec le temps,
je me suis rendu compte
que ce n’était pas la fin de tout,
mais le début d'autre chose.
Alors j’ai voyagé
pour être à la rencontre des gens
et de leur douleur.
J’ai partagé la mienne,
j’ai témoigné de la mienne,
là où je pouvais,
pour comprendre et pour guérir.
On ne trouve pas toujours les mots
pour pouvoir exprimer
ce qui nous foudroie de l’intérieur.
Mais avec le temps et pas à pas,
j’ai essayé de mettre de l’ordre
en moi-même
et j’ai pu avancer.
J’ai essayé d’acquérir
la vraie connaissance.
J'ai effectué des voyages humanitaires.
J'ai été à la rencontre des gens.
J’ai repris mes études au Maroc
en relations internationales et diplomatie
en études de paix et conflit.
Et surtout, je me suis reconnectée avec la
terre de mes ancêtres, avec mes racines,
ces montagnes du Rif au nord du Maroc.
Et là, tout est revenu :
Mes souvenirs d’enfance,
Mes souvenirs en famille,
cette grande table des fêtes, des Aïd,
ces moments en famille
de prières communes.
Tout est revenu.
Ces moments où on partait
au Maroc en vacances
visiter mes grands-parents.
Ce lien avec la nature,
les montagnes, la campagne.
Ce lien avec les animaux et la terre
que mes grands-parents avaient.
Et je me souviens de mon grand-père
qui parlait à ses arbres et à ses animaux.
Je me souviens de ma grand-mère
qui faisait sécher ses figues au soleil
qu’elle venait fraîchement de cueillir.
D’ailleurs c’est ce qui m’a permis
de m’intéresser à la permaculture
et à la protection de l’environnement,
pour revenir à une vie
plus saine et cohérente
avec des valeurs et des principes.
Et ça, ça répare vraiment.
J’ai continué mon chemin en continuant
à commémorer mes parents,
chaque année, chaque 7 mai,
depuis 21 ans cette année.
L’an dernier, lors des 20 ans,
j’ai fondé la Habiba Ahmed Foundation
pour la mémoire,
la transmission et la paix.
Cette fondation se trouve
dans la maison même où a eu lieu le drame.
Il y a eu un élan
de solidarité incroyable.
Il y a eu le soutien de parrains
et de marraines, de personnalités,
et surtout, des jeunes
qui ont tous porté ce message
d’espoir avec la fondation.
Vous me direz : « Pourquoi une Habiba
Ahmed Foundation après autant de temps ? »
Tout d’abord, et simplement,
par amour pour mes parents.
Pour dire qu’ils ont été là,
qu’ils ont existé parmi nous.
Pour dire aussi
qu’ils ne seront jamais réduits
qu’à des victimes du racisme.
Ils ont été beaucoup plus que ça.
Pour rendre hommage
à toutes les Habiba et à tous les Ahmed.
La deuxième raison,
c’est que je pense qu’on n’a pas
suffisamment compris notre histoire.
Ça me rappelle une citation d’Al-Ghazali,
ce savant et philosophe qui disait que
ce qui est important,
ce n’est pas qu’une personne ait raison,
mais que ce qui est vrai soit dit.
Alors j'aspire à dire ce qui est vrai,
avec mon cœur, avec mes mots.
Et si j’ai tenu autant de temps,
autant d’années,
c’est parce que je suis portée
par des convictions profondes.
Notre histoire -
Il y a eu beaucoup de racisme,
mais il y a eu aussi
beaucoup d’indifférence
et cet individualisme rampant,
qui rend opaque
à la souffrance de l’autre.
C’est un chemin qu’on mène souvent seul.
Je l’ai mené de manière sereine,
mais on est souvent seul.
Et c’est là que je me rappelle
les mots extraordinaires de Gaël Faye,
ce grand artiste,
au moment où il a accepté
d’être un des parrains de la fondation.
Je l’ai connu par l’intermédiaire
du dramaturge rwandais -
qui est devenu un grand frère -
Dorcy Rugamba.
Ce sont des personnes lumineuses
et on s’est très vite reconnus
parce qu’on porte les mêmes engagements.
Et Gaël m’a dit :
« Si je te dis
que tu peux compter sur moi,
c’est parce qu’on doit être ensemble,
on doit s’épauler et être solidaires.
On traverse tous ces déserts seul,
mais s’il y a une oasis, on peut se
retrouver ensemble pour suivre le chemin -
pour suivre ce chemin ensemble
et réparer ces tissus brisés
de nos sociétés. »
La Habiba Ahmed Foundation aspire
à porter un message
pour que plus personne ne soit isolé
avec sa douleur et seul.
Et c’est là que j’ai réalisé
en fait qu’il fallait absolument
cultiver une écoute profonde
et entretenir une culture de la paix.
Qu’est-ce que c’est, une écoute profonde ?
C’est une écoute
qui fait écho dans le cœur
de ceux qui souffrent
et qui sont en peine.
C’est une écoute
qui nous fait sortir de notre ego
pour agir avec sincérité,
intelligence, de manière responsable,
face aux injustices.
Je continue de porter ce message
parce que je pense
qu’il faut laisser de belles traces,
pour nos jeunes,
pour les générations futures
et pour rendre hommage
à toute cette génération de parents
dont mon grand-père fait partie.
Je pense qu’il faudrait
ne pas seulement
parler de vivre ensemble -
car nous vivons déjà ensemble,
mais l'un à côté de l'autre
et pas l’un avec l’autre -
mais plutôt parler de faire ensemble
pour une réelle transformation
positive et durable.
La Habiba Ahmed Foundation
propose deux initiatives.
Une rue et un jardin.
On aspire à renommer une partie
de la rue Van der Linden
en rue Habiba-Ahmed.
Une rue qui symboliserait
la paix et l’amour.
Cette rue où ont été
assassinés mes parents
pourrait représenter
toute cette génération de parents
qui ont tant fait pour la Belgique.
Ces parents immigrés
qui ont quitté leur pays
pour contribuer à la construction
de la Belgique.
Cette génération
dont fait partie mon grand-père.
Suite à l’appel de main-d’œuvre
de la Belgique,
il est arrivé fin des années 60
en Belgique
pour participer
à la reconstruction du pays,
marteau-piqueur à la main dans le métro,
dans des conditions de travail difficiles
et sans se plaindre.
Et ça, c’est
l’histoire collective belge aussi.
L'espace public devrait représenter
cette histoire aussi.
J’ai eu l’occasion de faire des voyages
aux États-Unis dans le cadre de mes études
et de mes interventions
en France, en Allemagne, aux Pays-Bas.
D’autres pays sont nettement en avance
sur cette question de la représentativité
dans l’espace public.
La deuxième initiative me rapproche de
mes origines rurales et environnementales.
La nature a beaucoup à nous apprendre.
Cette initiative, c’est la création
d’un jardin de la Paix,
un jardin dans le quartier
et surtout derrière la maison
où a eu lieu le drame.
Je pense que ce jardin avait déjà commencé
parce qu’on y avait planté deux arbres
à la demande de ma famille et moi-même,
symboliquement.
Ce jardin où peuvent se retrouver
les habitants, les voisins,
les membres d’une communauté humaine,
pour travailler la terre,
pour cultiver la terre
et peut-être cultiver la paix aussi,
pour enfin vivre l’un avec l’autre.
Ça me rappelle cette phrase de
Geoff Lawton, un grand permaculteur,
qui dit que tous les problèmes du monde
peuvent se résoudre dans un jardin.
J’espère qu’on n’attendra pas
vingt autres années
pour voir ces deux initiatives
se réaliser,
parce que j’ai conscience qu’elles
ne verront peut-être jamais le jour.
Mais au moins j’aurais fait comme
le colibri, j’aurais fait ma part.
Je pense qu’on est beaucoup
plus nombreux à vouloir la paix.
Je pense qu’on est beaucoup plus que ceux
qui portent et diffusent ces messages
de haine et de violence
qui nous divisent.
Un jour,
je rejoindrai mes parents au ciel
où ils reposent en paix.
J’aspire à terminer mon voyage dans
ce monde en ayant contribué à la paix,
en ayant rendu le sourire
à ceux qui en ont besoin,
en ayant contribué au bien.
Aujourd’hui,
je porte une gratitude immense d’être là,
d’avoir tenu,
de n’avoir jamais lâché,
d’avoir gardé la foi,
d’être revenue à l’essentiel.
Je suis revenue à mes racines,
je suis revenue à mon histoire,
à ces valeurs
que mes parents m’ont transmises.
J’espère réaliser une partie
de cette citation qui me tient à cœur,
qui m’a permis de prendre de la hauteur
et de rester alignée.
Elle est de [inaudible] et elle dit :
« Peu importe les bruits de l’âme,
peu importe les bruits du monde
ou de l’âme,
la vérité sera toujours la vérité,
la paix sera toujours la paix
et la beauté sera toujours la beauté. »
Dans ma tradition,
On se dit aussi au revoir
en se souhaitant la paix.
Alors je vous dis à nouveau
Salam aleykoum, que la paix soit sur vous,
et ceux que vous aimez.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)